when we go to northern boroughs we're
not just going to a landscape we're
going to a place an environment a
habitat which is the home of many other
living creatures and we share it with
them whether they be sheep or ponies
birds or insects or flowers all of these
creatures come together to make the
place somewhere very special indeed
a couple of dozen ponies live on the
burros and they're wandering herd gives
the place a sense of wildness
even the Sheep helped to bring the place
alive and sometimes their mere presence
can add real beauty to the landscape
under
beautiful in their own right
[Applause]
[Music]
the sheep live their own lives which
don't seem to be particularly exciting
but when the ponies get together they
have a real sense of fun
[Music]
not only that but sometimes they like to
engage with us too which makes them
particularly appealing
if you spend any amount of time
observing the sheep or the ponies most
of that time you'll be watching them
feeding most of what grows on the
burrows passes through them and that's
enormous ly important
but dong attracts insects and the
insects draw in the birds and the whole
ecosystem then becomes so much more
varied
[Applause]
these curlews find the burrows to their
liking and have come up from the salt
marshes to probe for insects in amongst
the sheep far more often you'll see the
black and white oyster catchers Anna
Restless scurrying flock of starlings
search energetically amongst the grasses
favoring the presence of the animals
where presumably the food supplies so
much greater it's only because of the
grazing activities of the sheep and
ponies keeping the grass so short that a
huge variety of wild flowers can exist
on the burrows and when night falls
other animals at their contribution
[Applause]
[Applause]
of course all life on the burros depends
on the seasons and as winter approaches
life becomes harder for those who live
there waders and seabirds may be able to
find abundant food when conditions are
right but for the animals and birds
which are land-based it's a different
story altogether
only the sighted sound of the golden
plover on the mudflats echoes across the
snow
frost and snow transformed the landscape
and make it a different place a place of
beauty and wonder perhaps for us but a
place where food is hard to come by for
those who depend on the grass
if the ground is not frozen solid under
the blanket of snow the sheep and ponies
can generally find something but for the
little birds and others who have no
refuge and whose food is covered up life
is very hard indeed
little flocks of overwintering limits
will be scratching around along the
shoreline to try and find a few morsels
and so will skylarks who have stayed to
endure the winter but when the snow and
ice permit it's up on the grassland of
the burrows that there are more likely
to be richer pickings
up here you'll find flocks of rooks and
jackdaws gathering together all
searching and probing and seeing what
they can find
although they come together in flocks in
the winter the jackdaws lived together
as a pair throughout the year they're
having to share one small bath may
strain domestic harmony alongside the
rooks and the jackdaws other crow
species the Magpies and the carrion crow
are also busy searching for food
throughout the winter
the Lapwing with their elegant crests
have come down to us from the north of
the country to overwinter here in search
of food
they are red-listed species in steep
national decline
these oystercatchers are far more
familiar to us most of the time spending
their life on the seashore but also
coming up frequently to forage on the
land as well but it's only on the scone
that the living is good and this is the
time when huge flocks of ducks geese and
waders come to join us on the burrows
the resident population of blackbirds is
greatly boosted during the winter and
many thrushes to join in the worms
packing the well-stocked ground provide
them a valuable source of food sometimes
in the depths of winter we see red wings
flitting about as well come to us from
the far east of Europe to find food to
sustain them through the winter
the landscape may be completely
transformed and grind way we would
expect to see sheep grazing turn into
seasonal Lakes attracting Canada geese
from further up the estuary this
handsome black-headed gull is in winter
plumage and is making good use of the
fresh water which is so abundant on the
burrows at this time of year meanwhile a
meadow Pipit searches busily around the
edges of the pools looking for food
a sky
mark is still searching around on the
beach but things are about to change the
grassland now thaws out food becomes
more abundant days become warmer the
skylark seem to sense that spring is
going to come they start to take their
higher perches and once more the air
begins to be filled with their glorious
song the black thorn breaks into flower
long before the leaves emerge spring is
truly on the way the use are normally
taken away from the burrows of this time
of year to give birth in safety but this
one obviously escaped the roundup now
the birds start to take to their high
perches they want to be seen breeding
season is approaching
[Laughter]
once they're big enough the other Lambs
are brought back to the burrows and this
is one of the most beautiful times of
the year with the longer days come the
first flowers
these include thistles and Heinz tongue
an attractive flower when you look at it
closely
and lower to the ground to the grass
becomes studded with flowers of many
kinds
and with the flowers the first
bumblebees make their appearance for
then the thistles offer rich pickings
but pollen is so tight wherever it can
be found
and the first butterflies appear perhaps
these painted ladies who have come to us
after a long migration searching out the
first flowers even thus edges are in
bloom for a large part of the year the
little Pied wagtail could be seen busily
dashing and darting about
and at the other end of the scale the
slow and ponderous rooks are frequently
present but when the rooks start
engaging in courting behavior than you
know that change is in the air the
resident birds of the borough's take up
their high perches and sing all day long
to attract mates and proclaim
territories the normally shy wrens seem
to pop up everywhere singing as loudly
as they possibly can black birds
suddenly become very conspicuous I'm the
normally secretive donik pauses music
into the air
robin's are never shy but are now even
more keen to be seen the keenly guard
their territories and this one is
hopping mad at someone who has come too
close
the skylarks are looking sleek and fit
finding plenty to eat now
and the males have developed showy
crests on their heads to go with their
showy songs for many months now the
borough's will be covered by the sound
of the glorious skylarks the stone chat
is never a shy bird will always take
high perches and will always scold
anyone who goes near the handsome black
capped one is the male
these are the limits only a twittering
song but the male's develop a lovely
rosy plumage during the breeding season
all year round the limits are one of
them is frequently seen small birds in
the burrows usually in a flock but not
during the breeding season day by day
the abundance and variety of the flowers
increases and everywhere living
creatures become more conspicuous and
abundant this woolly bear caterpillar is
the larva of the garden tiger moth
some of the borough's most important
rare plants now come into bloom such as
this deadly poisonous henbane or the
very scarce sea stock
a huge variety of small colorful flowers
is able to spring up where the grass has
been closely cropped
and a beautiful population of pyramidal
orchids shows itself in the protected
areas of the boroughs where animals
can't graze the insect life of the
borough is now greatly increases in
abundance everywhere there are predators
and prey this formidable predator is the
labyrinth spider the huge flocks of
winter migrants which occupied the scone
have now returned to their breeding
grounds leaving only a small number of
residents but now a different wave of
migrants comes summer residents
attracted to the borough's by the wealth
of insect life plentiful food for them
[Music]
some of the most conspicuous of the
early arrivals are the Housemartins and
swallows who've traveled hundreds or
thousands of miles up from Africa to
feast on the insects here are these
swallows are hunting along the pill
picking off the insects just above the
water and out on the grassland occupying
the highest perches dashing and darting
about on the grass for insects are the
wheat ears the males with a conspicuous
banded like mask
[Music]
you're far less likely to see the white
throat a very shy bird who throws out a
hasty scribble of a song and as soon as
anyone comes near darts down into the
undergrowth into cover
but surely the sedge Warbler is the most
extrovert of all the summer visitors he
bursts with eagerness to be seen and
heard and strange every fibre pouring
for his song as the warmth increases and
the abundance of flowers more and more
butterfly species make their appearance
very often the speckled wood is one of
the first native born species we see and
on northern boroughs we soon see the
first common blues as well and their
numbers will build and build
as the season develops many people think
of a rag wood as an unwelcome weed but
it flowers early in the year and its
many heads provide a wonderful source of
food for a great variety of insects many
which depend on it the red coated
beetles are soldier beetles ragwort is a
staple food plant of the caterpillars of
the cinnabar moth these brightly striped
ones here
the blackened red cinnabar moth could
easily be confused with the six spot
Burnet which is seen in huge numbers
these handsome moths just cannot be
missed when it's their time of year the
reason there are so many on the burrows
is the presence of the bird's foot
trefoil which is the food of their
caterpillars
once the caterpillars are mature enough
they will climb high up and find a place
to turn into moths
they will weave silky cocoon around
themselves and inside that papery cocoon
the transformation will take place the
caterpillar absorbs cyanide from the
plants they eat and this is passed on to
the moths as well we can think of the
bright colors of a moth as a warning
sign
once the moth has fought its way out of
its cocoon its first priorities are to
expand its wings and to feed and to mate
in peak season the air will be full of
hundreds of moth all the attention of
the birds is now focused on building
nests and producing young
driving community of house sparrows on
the birds and truth' their name many of
them actually choose to make their nests
inside the visitors center
before much longer
there are juvenile birds around like
these young wheat ears the male limit
here is helping to feed the youngsters
young starlings join their flock and
gradually they lose their brown plumage
and take on the speckles of the adults
everywhere young goldfinches may be seen
lacking the red faces which they would
develop within a few weeks
from an early age the young stone charts
are just as conspicuous as their parents
the borough's offers a wide range of
flowers and vegetation and this attracts
a wide range of butterflies the ringlet
is named for the markings on the
underside of its wings but from above it
can seem almost [ __ ] black it's mainly
found in grassy areas where it's
caterpillars must feed
the mouth of the meadow Brown can easily
be mistaken for the ringlet but the
females have a lot more orange on the
upper side of their wings the third
grassland species is the gatekeeper
similar to the meadow Brown but usually
smaller and brighter and a fourth
species which thrives in the grasses of
the burrows is the more unusually shaped
large skipper all of these species are
only on the berries because of the wide
range of grasses their which their
caterpillars depend upon but the
caterpillars of the small tortoiseshell
feed on stinging nettles the
caterpillars of the Red Admiral of the
peacock also eats stinging nettles but
all of these butterflies in their adult
form need plenty of nectar from the
flowers to keep them going wherever
there are plenty of flowers you can
expect to see plenty of butterflies on a
bright sunny day
the common blue is one of the most
conspicuous butterflies out on the open
grassland but all the species congregate
where the food is richest
the brown argus is easily overlooked but
is a very handsome butterfly when you
look at it closely
and this is the dark green fritillary
very rarely seen on the burroughs
burnett moths and many species of
butterflies congregate on the rag word
which blooms early in the season
the multiple Daisy heads of the plant
provide abundant net a sustaining food
and the bramble which overlaps with the
rag word is a wonderfully attractive
plant to bees and insects of all kinds
but if bumblebees have a preference it's
almost certainly for thistles especially
the handsome nodding or musk thistle
which is so striking in certain areas of
the burrows these large thistles mostly
grow around the edge of the grassland
which is one of the most important
habitats of the burrows
as has been mentioned to grow
and are created and kept in order by the
grazing animals without them the huge
variety of wild flowers should not be
possible the areas of chamomile lawn are
a particular treasure on the burrows
this scented Daisy
grows only in sandy soils and
close-cropped grassland it is a
vulnerable species classed in danger of
national extinction
when habitat often overlooked is the
waterways of the borough's during the
highest spring tides the the channel
known as the Pihl floods and the water
sometimes brings in gray mullet which
remain trapped there some of the smaller
channels are largely of fresh water but
stickleback are present and they can
live in either fresh or saltwater one of
the most important habitats is of course
the area of sand dunes especially that
protected by the fence near the visitors
center it's here that we find the rare
sea stock as well as many other
important plants typical of this sandy
ground is the Buckhorn plantain the
scarlet pimpernel the hop trefoil
the lovely little dune pansy
and water-retaining succulents such as
the yellow biting stone crop and the
white stone crop this is the bittersweet
or woody nightshade and these pink
flowers are the century
the sea rocket is a member of the
cabbage family not an impressive plant
at first sight but its nectar is much
sought after by many insects
[Applause]
the more grassy areas are where we find
the rag Wert and the pyramidal orchid
and in this area we also find tall
yarrow
with their lovely multiple heads and the
tall and impressive evening primrose
plants
an abundance of other creatures lives
here beside flowers but usually we can
only see their tracks
just occasionally we may be lucky enough
to see one of the residents out to warm
up in the sunshine
not surprisingly the sand dunes are a
favorite hunting ground for the kestrels
in the harsh habitat very close to the
sea gross the black knightshade in
sprawling masses here too is the dwarf
mallow
and the henbane which we've seen before
this poisonous plant was supposed to
help witches and wizards to fly and dr.
Crippen used it to poison his wife
this little plant is a frosted orage
with its tiny flowers and the prickly
salt work is another strandline plant
very resilient and built to resist
desiccation
in the heat of summer the ponies no
longer have the energy to gallop around
and towards the end of the breeding
season the Skylark seemed happy to
gather together and enjoy sand baths but
they will continue to sing for some time
yet sheep who were lucky enough to find
it rest in the shade and water can be in
very short supply with even tiny pools
visited by many clients
butterflies continue to feed on such
flowers as they can find
and it is in these long dry days that
gray sands is a particularly attractive
place for many creatures
this one is the scarce dune chafer
beetle
are adapted to try conditions and can be
at their best at this hot time of year
this sprawling plant with the pink
flowers is rest Harrow which helps hold
the soil together
this is storks bill a food plant of the
brown argus caterpillar
the yellow flowers a lady's bed straw is
found in many places on the burrows but
thrives here particularly the handsome
see bindweed is a characteristic plant
of grey sands and is quite scarce
nationally and these are key plants at
Grace and the marram grass which holds
the sand together cease purge and to see
Holly this is cease purge it is a
succulent and like the sea Holly
very resistant to drying out see Holly
dies away completely over winter but
when it comes up again and comes into
bloom it is a mecca for insects
this is called the blackened red squash
burg or cinnamon bug butterflies are
drawn to the nectar provided by the
flowers and bees compete for nectar and
pollen
see Holly flowers late in the season and
many species of butterflies are drawn to
it
the little butterfly here is the small
copper
and a late generation of painted ladies
is very happy to find the flowers
but mostly we are likely to see the
common blue and the brown Argus the
little male common Blues are easily
recognized but this is a brown Argus and
that can easily be confused with a
female common blue such as this it can
be very hard to tell the difference this
can easily be recognized as a female
common blue from its bluish Sheen but
many don't have that here the female and
male common blues are conveniently seen
together
this is hemp agrimony a plant of damp
grassland and away from Grayson's the
last refuges of flowers and insects at
the end of a hot summer of the damp and
shady areas surrounded by scrub this is
tufted veg
this is a species of a human wasp very
likely the one which lays its eggs
inside the eggs of hover flies
here is st. John's word I bright red bar
Xia this is agrimony completely
different from hemp agrimony this is mix
of fleabane and water mint that is most
characteristic of the damp areas and
water mint is another flower that is a
particularly important food source for
insect at this time of year it's very
easily recognized by its strong scent
[Music]
the insect here is a hover fly
the fleabane is a handsome yellow Daisy
very conspicuous from late summer
through into autumn
and here being visited by a solitary bee
what's the breeding season
many birds come together in large flocks
not least the noisy congregation of
starlings which are so conspicuous on
the burrows
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Linux joined together enlarged
twittering flocks very often spending a
lot of time down on the grasses of the
scone many of the Goldfinch is migrated
but by no means all and quite large
flocks of those remain to feed on the
borough's
[Music]
as long as any fischels Romanian flower
they are an important food source for
the last of the years butterflies
but as they do turn to seed goldfinches
spend hours and days and weeks feeding
on them fattening up for the winter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
increasingly the colors now are the
colors of autumn this is prime time for
spiders and cobwebs are all around it's
the season of mists and mellow
fruitfulness and where there were
flowers is an hour rich larder of fruit
and seeds
these busy creatures are harvest men
related to spiders but they don't weave
webs they have no fangs and they catch
their prey with claws on their feet
when we see funky everywhere we know
that autumn has well and truly come
[Music]
any summer migrant birds who have not
already left will be leaving very soon
they might include these green finches
because many birds gather together in
flocks of the same species and all go
off together pollute it's rarely migrate
these may be only fattening up for the
winter but they are not normally seen
here
the atmosphere of the burros is subdued
or there the shaggy inked-up funghi are
now spreading everywhere and in their
prime
with the return of the Frost's the year
has turned a full circle mists rise from
the river
and it is now to the scone that we must
look to find thrive in life
[Music]
winter migrants are here in full number
and will see us through until the spring